this is a story about networking once
upon a time when you wanted to set up a
private network or subnet to host your
workloads in the cloud you had to
construct a virtual private cloud or VPC
contained just one region this was okay
as long as you were only managing two or
three but scaling up became really hard
because you needed VPNs between each
region to keep your traffic secure and
this meant longer wait times at Google
we imagined a single global VPC where
VMs in regional subnets could
communicate privately across the world
and all of this without going through a
VPN and then we built it this global VPC
approach allowed for simplicity at scale
empowering businesses to add subnet
after subnet without a resulting network
that was too unwieldy to manage for
network professionals who lived in both
worlds the differences
well noticeable just ask anybody who
spent time stitching together VPN
gateway after gateway ask anybody who's
had to pinpoint the source of a network
problem in a system of localized V pcs
when something breaks or anybody who's
had to manage security policies for
those different B pcs or anyone trying
to maintain clear segregation of their
engineers access to each network when
you use Google's Network you'll reap all
the benefits of skilling without any of
these drawbacks so what makes this all
possible originally we built our own
network because quite simply we couldn't
buy for any price the scale and
performance we needed so what did we
have to do differently to solve for the
scale and performance when designing our
own network a big part of the answer
tail latency when you're doing any kind
of distributed computation you don't
just care about how fast you can get the
data most of the time you care about
what happens to the speed at the tail
end of the distribution to understand
why suppose you have a computation that
starts at one server collects data and
doesn't finish until it collects data
from 1,000 more servers if even one of
those service returns your queries
significantly later than the rest well
the speed of your computation is only as
fast as a slowest server
but at Google by guaranteeing that the
worst case is very close to the best
case we design our network for what
matters most predictability it's this
network and the philosophy driving it
that allows us to treat your hundreds
sometimes thousands of servers as one
unit of computation one collective brain
talking to itself across locations
around the globe and what does this mean
for you when designing services for your
customers you get to assume low latency
in large part this is thanks to
best-in-class global load balancing
services which support one million-plus
queries per second traffic enters cloud
global load balancing through 80 plus
distinct global load balancing locations
meaning your traffic primarily stays on
Google's fast Private Network backbone
instead of public Internet service
providers and naturally this design can
accommodate huge unexpected spikes in
traffic so when your app becomes a crowd
favorite overnight our network
intelligently directs traffic to VM
instances that can be configured to spin
up automatically in a matter of seconds
in other words we're not just hoping
your business will grow we're counting
on it of course we also know that one
size doesn't fit all and that there will
always be a few niche cases where you
might still want to set up a separate
regional VPC so we built that option
right in with Google's network you can
take advantage of our global VP see when
it makes sense and go the traditional
route when you need to if you're ready
to see for yourself head to
cloud.google.com but the story doesn't
end there there's so much more we could
say about networks actually we created a
whole series cloud networking end-to-end
dedicated to answering all the questions
you've ever had about networking and
some you didn't ever wondered how to set
up your own VPC on google cloud hybrid
connectivity firewall rules or external
load balancers so be sure to check out
cloud networking end to end as well as a
bunch of other great content on the
Google cloud platform YouTube channel
[Music]